but we begin of course with that large
and powerful and dangerous winter storm
taking aim at about a third of the
nation this weekend the storm rapidly
moved from the central plains to the
Midwest and is now taking aim at the
Northeast with it comes snow sleet
freezing rain and ice in many places
after that temperatures are expected to
turn bitterly cold in Iowa Friday a
truck jackknifed on snow-covered
Interstate 35 when driven snow had
reduced visibility to less than half a
mile on many of the state's roads in
Minnesota the interstate was closed
Friday after accidents on the icy road
parts of the state may get more than
eight inches of snow this weekend and in
Omaha Nebraska Southwest Airlines Boeing
737 from Las Vegas skidded off an icy
runway Friday there were no reported
injuries there which is good news so far
more than 1,100 airline flights have
been canceled today the bad news and
that is due to the weather the weather
also going to affect millions taking
part in the women's March today for the
latest on the storm and for the rest of
the nation's weather here's
meteorologist Chelsea Ingraham of our
Philadelphia station kyw-tv Chelsea yeah
ain't looking good for us this weekend I
know Michelle this is a very complex
system that we're dealing with and it
all depends on where you live as to what
type of precipitation you are going to
be seeing especially as we head into the
Northeast let's start with what's going
on right now we have some very heavy
rain even some ongoing severe weather
down into the Lower Mississippi area
we'll zoom you in where we have some
heavy snow around Chicago into the Great
Lakes region so this is just a mess of a
system we have winter weather alerts
that span all the way from st. Louis
check this out all the way up into
Portland Maine so winter storm warnings
and winter weather advisories going into
effect for a lot of folks and it's all
due to this this area of low pressure
that's going to continue tracking toward
the east
it'll be interior sections of the
Northeast that pick up the bulk of the
snowfall meanwhile a lot of rain
expected in and along the i-95 corridor
across the mid-atlantic and then it's
what's behind this system that is going
to bring us
extremely cold air as it moves on out
future snow amounts generally up to
around fourteen point one inches or two
inches in Albany upwards of two feet in
some locations though that's all
followed by a flash freeze on Sunday and
then sub-zero wind chills as we head
into Monday Dana are you alright Chelsea
if I state the obvious it is January
Thank You Chelsea